that's hiding no but yeah but jealous
[ __ ] I'm sorry steven crowder dies is
my fault
haha I was getting blamed yeah moved
around a lot
yeah no I know yeah yeah that's true but
remember he did that thing that Bob Ross
paints Mohammed yeah yeah - that took
balls yeah you know I mean it's
literally something that they're allowed
to kill you if you do and he did that
allowed yeah I mean it's strange time I
mean this is also a time where that
criticizing that criticizing anything
that's Islamic is very dangerous because
people call you Islamophobia and because
people want to kill you I got two
different things going on at the same
time but those same people will have no
problem mocking Christians
I don't yeah yeah I'm not even like I'm
not a right wing guy I consider myself a
little more to the left but there's
something I like about right-wing media
especially like the funny type of
right-wing media that they take [ __ ]
crazy risks you mean like oomiya like
like oomiya like Crowder like steven
crowder is really funny takes like likes
Gavin McInnes I think is [ __ ]
hilarious
Gavin's in the crossfire right now he's
the Eye of Sauron is upon him he's yeah
I said too much to pitch it about like
inciting violence and now that there's
some article saying that the FBI
considers him that the proud boys are
hain't group but then COO Mia sent me
something that he sent him and I'll sent
it to you he's saying it's [ __ ] the
first time I heard about the proud boys
I was doing Gavin show New York
I know he was with Dante narrow which is
a black comic and in New York and he was
like hey me and him are in the proud
boys and I was like boys let's explain
what it what it actually is there's a
joke at first it was like we don't jerk
off so that we'll want to [ __ ] our wives
and then like four months later I was
like oh yeah I'm against quit the proud
boys today well you know oh is it today
I thought he had quit that years ago
though this just got posted I think
maybe Jamie I'm sending you an article
to where he's realizing how problematic
it is yeah he connected with these
people
and you know look it's one of those
[ __ ] things you want to have a group
you can't control everyone in the group
so anybody in the group that does
something horrible I just sent you
something
pull this up this is Gavin's response to
all this because so many people got mad
at me that I had Gavin on in the first
place first of all I had Gavin on
because he used to be one of the
founders advice also because I had Gavin
on before that and he was fun to hang
out with then when I had him on did he
become with when I had him on the last
time one of the things that he was
talking about was the proud boys I don't
even know what the [ __ ] that was I think
maybe I had heard of it but I thought it
was a joke
turned out he used to be a joke it
started off as a joke on compound media
and Anthony will get into it better he
knows the history of it but they were
making fun of something and they decided
to make a fake mock group crawled the
proud boys now the problem with this is
when you have a group that's supposed to
be fighting and Tifa and I actually
tried to express this to him when he was
on the show because he was talking about
kicking people's ass we're gonna punch
him in the face I'm telling him to punch
people in the face I'm like okay that's
not how reality works like I don't know
have you ever been punched in the face
or if you've been around people that
like to punch people in the face but you
don't just punch someone in the face
what happens is you punch them in the
face they come back with a bat somebody
gets a knife people get guns it always
escalates it's gonna keep going you
don't just get away with punching people
in the face you know and yeah it's not
good that these Antipa people bring by
clocks and smack people in the heads
with them and that's kind of the point
in that in the first place those people
don't understand what happens when you
start the chain of violence when you
start that domino chain they don't
understand what happens they think that
they live it in some [ __ ] book that
they love about some revolutionary
liberal character that you know reaches
out and and and smashes all these
oppressors of social justice some
reality in reality you just hit a guy
with a lock who's talking to you you
assaulted them with a deadly weapon and
the next thing you know they're gonna
kill you are they gonna beat you they're
gonna punch you so when a guy like Gavin
says something like you should punch
them in the face I understand why he
said that because they were inciting
violence these these nt4 people would
hit people with things that were in
masks they some of them some of them
were doing it non-violently some of them
just wanted what they thought was the
right things to happen but like all
groups
you get a [ __ ] big group you can't
control everybody in the nude
and that happened with the proud boys
too I think I think he decided to have
this thing that was gonna you know
mockingly oppose and Tifa then it became
real and then it became violence and
this this is this is just one of the
problems that people have when there's a
[ __ ] group of people opposed to
another group of people and you know him
quitting the proud boys is definitely
smart but I don't think it's gonna help
because now people are there's they're
saying he's a white supremacist and yeah
what the perception that people have of
you is almost important almost as
important what as what you actually do
it's probably even more important almost
yeah because if not for you and not for
me not for people that are gonna
actually read into it but for people on
the outside the perception of who you
are is is there's too many things to
learn okay he's a racist oh [ __ ] that
racist that's all people hear that's all
they say and then they keep moving
meanwhile you got a guy who's Gavin who
first of all he's not even American he's
Canadian second of all he's married to a
Native American woman he is not a racist
he says he's a provocateur a hundred
percent unquestionably he says
ridiculous [ __ ] cuz he thinks it's funny
but he's in a very bad situation it's
almost a troll or like I didn't even
think like I know him I'd like we're not
good good friends but I like him a lot
and I'm pretty sure he's not even
right-wing I think he's just [ __ ] yeah
he's definitely [ __ ] with people and
he definitely has some right-wing ideas
but more than that he doesn't like some
of the ridiculous aspects of the left so
it's more in its again like he's a more
opposed to some of the more preposterous
notions over left then he is really
right yeah but he's right on some things
to a right-wing on some things but is
like he came onto the show dressed like
[ __ ] Michael Douglas from falling
down as a goof he brought us free tastes
and everything we're a tie and the white
short sleeve button-up shirt he did it
as a goof like that's him he's a he's a
weird guy and it's funny
he says funny [ __ ] but he but in this
when you here's there's two different
ways you can go through life right you
could pretend and put on an act or you
could be yourself
what he's chosen to do is a little bit
of both he's chosen to pretend a little
bit but also be himself so it's hard for
people to know where the line is yeah
that's fun that's fun if you're getting
away with it it's not fun when it turns
on you yeah and then you go no that part
I was joking around about people like
says who
like who's right who's wrong like it
it's it gets it gets real slippery when
people don't actually know who you are
where you stand
yeah and I think he was Joe he thought
it was fun to [ __ ] with people a little
bit on with certain things and in this
climate man that can be [ __ ]
dangerous
yeah that's Andy Kaufman of 2018 no he's
not
he's different thing he's Gavin McInnes
you know and I really I'm sad that all
this [ __ ] is going down and I hope it
passes over and and people get to
understand he's not perfect person but
no one is but what he is is an
interesting guy was weird says funny
[ __ ] did he take a [ __ ] on the air once
on his show he stuck his finger up his
ass and [ __ ] I done some work he's not a
bad guy he's a maniac yeah